everything you ever knew about the lord
of the rings is a lie why did peter
jackson change so much from the books
keep watching to find out
perhaps the biggest misconception
regarding the world of middle earth is
that hobbits are as a race pretty weak
sure bilbo and frodo are heroic but most
fans think of them as exceptions from
the norm however the truth is that
hobbits can be quite sturdy and quite
fierce this is most evident in a key
part of the return of the king that is
actually emitted from the cinematic
adaptation where a de-powered saruman
leads a group of human ruffians to take
over the shire when frodo sam mary and
pippin return home they lead a revolt
and drive off the humans in fact when
nearly 100 humans come to try to reclaim
the shire 70 of them are killed in
combat with the hobbits many of them cut
down by axes why then did peter jackson
omit this from his hit movie other than
a brief glimpse in a vision during the
fellowship of the ring it's possible
that the universe would collapse under
the weight of yet another ending being
added to that movie so the hobbits get a
more traditional happy ending
one of the misconceptions about the lord
of the rings is that samwise gamgee is
little more than a source of comedic
relief and funny memes potatoes
boil em mash em stick em in a stew
however the most badass samwise gamgee
moment is one that is very easy to miss
when sam thinks that frodo has been
killed by sheila the giant spider sam
takes the ring to continue the quest
alone if that wasn't badass enough once
he saves frodo he just gives the ring
back why is this a big deal there are
almost no other instances of the ring
being freely given away remember it's a
huge deal when bilbo does it at the
start of the trilogy and at the end of
the tale gollum inadvertently saves the
day when he nibbles it off of frodo
because as it turns out frodo himself is
unable to willingly give it up
a common criticism of lord of the rings
is the fact that gandalf didn't just
summon some of those giant birds to
carry the fellowship to mordor the truth
is that using the great eagles in that
way was never an option first there's no
reason to think sauron wouldn't be ready
for an enemy to approach mordor from the
air remember all those nazgul on their
big dragons until sauron was defeated
the eagles couldn't easily get into
mordor second it's a flawed assumption
that gandalf could summon the great
eagles at will gandalf did not summon
the great eagles they came of their own
accord tolkien often portrays animals in
his stories as being blessed with as
much intelligence as humans as early as
the great eagle's first appearance in
the hobbit writer j.r.r tolkien made it
clear that the great eagles did not like
most two-legged things and would rarely
get involved with them they respected
gambolf and would occasionally help him
but they were never at his command even
to save middle earth from sauron
another misconception about lord of the
rings that can be blamed entirely on the
movies is that losing the ring leads to
instant aging
this is dramatized by the extreme
contrast of bilbo's relative youth at
the beginning of the first movie when he
is celebrating turning 111 years old and
his extremely elderly appearance when
they encounter him in rivendell now the
movies are deliberately cagey about the
timeline but the books tell us that 17
years pass between that birthday
celebration and frodo's quest and then
more years pass after the quest before
bilbo's ship leaves in that time bilbo
has seemingly aged quite a few decades
leading some fans to conclude that
losing the ring caused him to age
however this is canonically the opposite
of the truth and we know this because of
gollum gollum was pushing 600 years old
by the time he died and he had been
without the ring for over 60 years by
the time that happened if losing the
ring leads to the body's age catching up
gollum should have been dust well before
the fellowship of the ring even began
among die hard lord of the rings fans
there are four words almost guaranteed
to instigate a blind rage elves at
helm's deep this of course was a major
part of the climax of the two towers
movie with a small company of elves
arriving to help the beleaguered humans
drive off an entire host of invading
orcs and because these are adaptations
of a beloved series of books many people
figured this too was in the books but
not only was this event not in the books
it was canonically impossible in the
books peter jackson made the bold
decision to start his film adaptations
by showing audiences a pivotal moment in
the history of middle earth humans and
elves standing together to defeat sauron
this was notable not just because they
defeated sauron but because this was the
last alliance between the two races they
went back to each doing their own thing
and by the time the main events of the
modern plot unfold the elves are fading
in prominence from middle earth remember
it's actually a major plot point that
big important elrond has assembled a
team of humans hobbits a dwarf and a
wizard the elves are supposed to be
leaving this world behind and letting
the immortal races deal with their own
problems so having elves show up at
helm's deep violates a major theme of
the entire series
while books are perfect places for
illusions and metaphors it is the job of
the movie to visually spell everything
out peter jackson took his role very
seriously when it came to return of the
king leading to one of our primary
misconceptions that sauron is a giant
eyeball when audiences first see sauron
he is a towering warrior in the
flashback battle sequence at the
beginning of fellowship of the ring when
they next see him though he is seemingly
a giant eye one that aragorn resolves to
distract with a flashy battle sequence
while sam and frodo finished their task
this giant eyeball is a creation made
especially for the movies and it makes
many people think that the eye is
literally sauron however tolkien's own
letters clarify that sauron had a
physical body by the time the ring was
physically destroyed something hinted at
in the hobbit prequel films
thanks to vigo mortensen and the face
that launched a thousand fanfics it's
easy to take aragorn's age for granted
after all mortensen was 43 years old
when fellowship of the ring came out and
it seemed a reasonable age for a
seasoned warrior who can still kick
orcish ass however the character of
aragorn is supposed to be twice that age
at the time of their adventures there's
even a deleted scene where eowyn is
highly confused when aragorn tells her
that he fought in battle alongside her
grandfather then you must be at least
sixty
seventy
you cannot be eighty
so what's up with this exceptionally old
age aragorn was not like mortal men as
he was the sildore's heir was the last
of the numenoreans a group of humans
with exceptionally long life whose
homeland was destroyed in an
atlantis-style cataclysm long ago
this is part of the tragic history the
character often bears with him and is
part of his concern that he may repeat
some of the same errors that his
ancestors did
one of the most powerful moments from
return of the king is when eowyn the
shield maiden defeats the witch king the
witch king feels quite confident because
of a prophecy that no man can kill him
at which point aoen disguised as a male
warrior reveals that she is a woman and
stabs him in the face
i am no man
but mary deserves just as much credit
before aoen gets her awesome killing
stroke in audiences see mary stab the
witch king with his blade the movies
gloss over the importance of these
blades with aragorn simply handing them
out at weathertop the books however made
clear that mary's blade was forged with
magical enchantments specifically made
to hurt the witch king thus mary happens
to stab the witch king with one of the
only weapons that can hurt him opening
the door for aoen to complete the
prophecy
gandalf is a wizard yes but he's
actually not the kind of wizard we're
used to gandalf isn't a wizard in the
same way that say harry potter is a
wizard he's not someone who showed
aptitude for magic as a child and so was
sent to some wizard school and given a
big tome and taught a bunch of spells no
gandalf was created as a wizard and sent
to middle earth to protect it the valar
were essentially the gods of middle
earth and they sent gandalf there along
with saruman radagast and two other
wizards these five wizards acted as
agents of the gods they were made to
look human and given magical and
physical abilities beyond normal men
they existed for millennia even longer
than the elves this is why gandalf knows
so much it's why no matter where the
fellowship goes he's already been there
and always seems to know someone he's
been alive long enough to travel to
every corner of middle earth and back
again hundreds of times over and it's
why after he dies during his battle with
the balrog gandalf returns to life
because the gods resurrected him to
complete his mission to redeem the world
from the devil called sauron
denethor was portrayed as a vengeful and
cowardly madman in peter jackson's
return of the king john noble played
denathore to perfection but there was a
lot of information missing from the
movie that would have added more depth
to the character in the novel tolkien
makes it clear that denothor was
actually driven mad by an outside
magical influence by a palantir this is
the same sort of magic orb that also
corrupted saruman and almost possessed
pippin as it opens the user to sauron's
influence while denathor ultimately
failed as steward his fall is tragic he
was the leader of a besieged kingdom
searching for a way to stop an
unbeatable enemy he failed and the
consequence was madness but he went mad
trying to save his people and that's got
to count for something
peter jackson's adaptation of return of
the king may give you the impression
that gondor was the only place where
sauron's armies laid siege but that was
far from true this is alluded to briefly
in the extended version of return of the
king when legolas tells gimli he
believes the dwarves are busy with their
own battles but we don't hear any
specifics the appendices of lord of the
rings make it clear that at the same
time sauron's armies were smashing into
the walls of menace tirith the elves
dwarves and other humans of greater
middle-earth were dealing with their own
invasions
sauron's armies in dulgadur the
abandoned city where gandalf sauruman
and galadriel encounter sauron in the
hobbit movies attacked lorien three
times once sauron was finally defeated
galadriel traveled to the city and
destroyed it the wood elves were also
waging war against the orcs in their own
forests and eventually they managed to
expel them the humans of dale the city
at the foot of the lonely mountain in
the hobbit weren't as successful as the
elves though they were aided by the
dwarves sauron's armies attacked dale
and overwhelmed its defenders humans and
dwarves alike took shelter in the lonely
mountain and the orcs laid siege to its
gates once the one ring was destroyed
the combined armies of humans and
dwarves were able to route the orcs but
not before both the human and dwarven
kings were killed
though he ultimately betrays frodo and
the fellowship after being corrupted by
the one ring's power tolkien makes it
clear in his novel that boromir is
actually a noble warrior he's one of the
most skilled swordsmen in the fellowship
and possibly the strongest in battle
scenes he performs better than most with
the possible exception of aragorn he's
flawed but he's not the mess of nerves
peter jackson depicted in fellowship of
the rings except for his last stand
boromir is hardly seen in jackson's
fellowship battle scenes but the
extended edition of the film revealed a
number of cutscenes and lines that
showed him in a better light in a
lothlorian scene for example when the
rest of the fellowship is silent boromir
is the only one to reach out and tell
frodo not to blame himself for gandalf's
presumed death
gandalf's death was not in vain
nor would he have you give up hope
like his father boromir wasn't a bad guy
at all he was just a desperate man who
lost hope while trying to save his
people
many fans were quite annoyed by the film
portrayal of pharamir this is because it
led to this kind of widespread
assumption that pharamir is like boromir
light that is he's just another corrupt
and greedy human who is eager for glory
and power and he only changes his mind
at the 11th hour however the fair mere
of the books is the polar opposite of
boromir through a combination of
intelligent interrogation and sam's
inability to keep his mouth shut he
finds out that they are carrying a
powerful weapon against sauron one that
boromir greatly desired for humanity to
have and when the pharamir of the books
finds this out he merely reiterates his
promise to help the hobbits out because
he had made a vow unlike peter jackson's
version who initially decides to turn
them over to dad to score some points
not cool
at some point it just became an
unquestioned truth that hobbit feet
along with being hairy and necessarily
resilient are disproportionately large
like if you took a clown and magically
turned his floppy clown shoes into
exceptionally hairy feet that's what
hobbit feet look like in the films the
truth is that tolkien never wrote
anything about hobbit feet being
particularly large in fellowship of the
ring he wrote that hobbit feet had quote
tough leathery soles and that they were
quote clad in a thick curling hair much
like the hair of their heads but he made
no mention about their feet being
particularly large sean astin who played
samwise gamgee in peter jackson's
adaptations would likely have preferred
a more faithful interpretation in the a
day in the life of a hobbit special
feature on the extended edition of
fellowship of the ring director peter
jackson revealed that aston annoyed at
the time it took to apply the hobbit
foot prosthetics kept jackson up to date
on his personal tally of how many days
the prosthetics were applied versus how
many days the feet appeared in shots we
have to be really honest and say that
when the days that we don't have feet
we're really excited
partly due to the enduring popularity of
the lord of the rings elves remain a
staple of high fantasy and their
physical appearance tends to follow
specific rules they're all stunningly
beautiful creatures with men and women
sporting equally long and often blonde
hair and they have pointy ears but
tolkien never wrote that blonde hair was
a dominant feature of his elves in fact
many of them such as elrond and arwen
have black hair though legolas is almost
always portrayed as having blonde hair
tolkien never actually describes his
hair color legolas father thranduil
however is one of the few elves to
explicitly be described as blonde
tolkien also never wrote anything to the
effect of elf men having the same
straight long hair as women so that a
bunch of elf men and women together look
like a line of actors waiting for a
shampoo commercial audition in fact
believe it or not tolkien never even
wrote in any of his books that elf ears
were pointy maybe he never meant for
them to be thought of as pointy or maybe
he thought elves were common enough in
legend and myth that the detail wasn't
needed regardless unless someone shows
tolkien's elves baking cookies and trees
for keebler or making toys for santa we
can probably all agree they've gotten a
pretty good deal in pop culture so far
and don't have a lot to complain about
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you